like I like the stories I grew up
reading comic books are opening
spider-man and I'm all over the place I
enjoy paving big movies like this with a
lot of action like being in small movies
that cost 15 bucks and make you have to
bring your own clothes so well it's
shane's obviously bringing his own flair
to it and the script like I said is that
he and rural roads very very different
nuance in a very different way but it
still feels like a lot of the certain
things have to be paid off in the same
way and in fact Iowa sort of adaptive
Favreau I have to carry on what he
started without violating it the same
time he'll bring enjoyed my own
enhancement if I can but he's been
helping me give me tips and advice along
the way so this is a guy there's been
enormously generous for this time given
that he's not directing and still around
still wants to be in it just been so
gracious that I can see nothing but
wonderful things about how helpful even
that said yeah we'll look a little
different I hope I can protect one thing
I can't live without these people have
Marvel have done this a lot and they
hold your hand through the whole thing
so if I have a question about effects
I've learned more in a year now than
anybody else would in a decade but some
number
one heroes there is no such thing it
feels a little more scarily possible
yeah we had a kind of a conundrum and
that the Avengers opens up the chute sky
hole full of interdimensional aliens and
you kind of look back at it well you
know what do you do after that except go
back to sort of a more gritty intense
kind of techno-thriller room and saw the
script to know it wow that's a different
that's some different flavor just go in
and you wrestle yeah we got to just kind
of jerk things around a little bit and
mix it up it so that there's still more
story to tell and you're the way you do
that is you treat it like the first two
were part of an ongoing story that
hasn't finished yet the journeys are all
mythic in a way that we recognize from a
lot of years hundreds and hundreds and
thousands of years mythic superhero
stories today's world is so complicated
that the simplicity of myth has come
back round with a desire and I think a
need on the part of people to feel and
see that that's unprecedented given just
how confusing the world is right now
call me a terrorist
I consider myself a teacher
robert downey jr's character would not
dealing with his alcoholism but we ran
out of money so he there's a scene at
the end where he falls off a wagon as
part of the effect it was kind of last
min I